what did making a movie teach you about
filmmaking and the business
what did making a movie yeah and it
could have been your first movie could
have been subsequent movies when did you
finally feel like it clicked for you
like oh this is the moviemaking business
this isn't just being a bit the word
you're talking about the word business
yeah well I I think when I pitched the
wedding singer and I referenced the fact
that it's gonna be like Dazed and
Confused and the producers that they
think of use made like ten million
dollars why would you reference that
that's when I realized that when you're
trying to get a movie made it's all
about the box-office in in in the
Hollywood world a you know at the end of
the day it's an investment for somebody
and and they and they want to make sure
they make a lot of money so you start to
become aware that you have to let people
feel confident that the movie has
commercial appeal in that world and
that's part of the reason I enjoy now
delving into doing Indies because you
know you can have less pressure on that
and more pressure on just telling a
great story and you're you you do it for
not a lot of money with the freedom to
have creative control to make something
more specific that you want to do but
that would love to have Paul Thomas you
know Paul Thomas Anderson's career where
he gets a lot of money to do whatever he
wants
yeah but the one thing I think I learned
from making more commercial movies is I
try not to get up my own ass as far as
like I see younger filmmakers or I see
filmmakers that never had to do
commercial films and they sort of can
start to make every moment drawn-out and
what happens if you draw everything out
and make everything important then
everything's not important it's like I
think I've learned from making
commercial movies to not waste people's
time like let things breathe when they
have to but don't like be like
everything's great but because you
really can punctuate the things you want
by telling this story more succinctly
until it's that time
needs to breathe so I am kind of glad
the way my career was gone that I did my
first nd I've done a bunch of wider
appeal movies and now like when I made
this movie hi there I didn't have many
days at 20 days to shoot it in Manhattan
I didn't have the size crew or anything
it's even like it's smaller than a TV
crew I'd have like three grapes three
kafirs I'm really decisive so I'm able
to be much more you kind of know what
you want I was saying before students
like when you faked your first film what
you want what you get are so different
and that's the painful process of the
first time you make a movie and the one
thing that after time like what I have
in my head I can get much closer I mean
there's a lot of variables involved but
what I have in my head is a lot easy to
get really close so when I get in the
editing room I already know what I want
it feels good and it feels good and I
almost think it's great that I'm doing
hopefully gonna be doing more Indies now
because I can just make them much more
efficient than if it was my first or
second film so when you looked at the
footage for murdered innocence was it a
shock to you because you thought you
were getting one thing and it didn't
turn out that way it was by the time I
made murder since I had made enough
short films and even travel document I I
looked through the lens and edited stuff
enough that my skill set wasn't as good
as now I learned a lot like editing took
that movie took a lot longer than you
know I had to do this movie now hot air
and I edited in like 3 and a half months
my editor you know I while shooting I
see cut and I can give a million notes
and like I know what I want I'm not
afraid to experiment but you get all the
stuff the way you want and you get time
to experiment so yeah you just get
better at knowing what you want you get
better at knowing how things are gonna
feel you get better it's like another
reality of the movie and I have a more
vivid image of that reality that being
said though I always say like people
make their best films when they first
start making films and probably towards
the end of their
somebody else said that it's like when
you're really young you make films
because you're just daring and you don't
care and then when you're older you're
wiser so there's something to be said
about both ends of the spectrum
interesting so in the middle you think
people are too busy making something and
they're too worried because is this
gonna get me my next job yeah I'm not
sure of that
I hope I'm good in the middle too but
every movie from the first one to
everyone they do I don't know who has
the career where they know they're
definitely getting a movie maybe
Scorsese and Spielberg and you know even
Scorsese has to hustle a little bit but
the good thing about being him is he can
ask Leo or any great actor to be in his
movie and they're gonna say yes so well
that was a part of the beauty of Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood was that even
though this guy had what seemed like
success he was worried about getting the
next one yeah the other character Brad
Pitt's character was just you know yeah
I'm good yeah I'm good if I hopefully I
get something and I'll go up on a roof
and fix an antenna I think that was the
beauty no it was a great contrast yeah
but I always think I always think about
like Scorsese and Coppola what - my
favorite filmmaker seems like you know
obviously Apocalypse Now probably didn't
Godfather's and and and so many more and
I'm like why do you not want but I feel
like there was a period of time where he
did want to make films and it wasn't
that easy or he didn't want to he didn't
want to deal with it and it's it's just
sad to me that the industry can be very
forgetful of some great talents and yeah
it's not always fair some of the best by
George Roy hill was like one of my
favorite filmmakers needed this thing
and he did the world according to GARP
and
and then which Cassidy and and somebody
told me a cab driver goes yeah I joke I
joke
joy joy Hill ho is going wild back he
passed away yeah he's a little guy who
was a little apartment and I'm thinking
this guy made some of my favorite movies
and he just kind of like went away and
just you know I'm sure he would have
made more movies and I always get really
sad I hope that's not me ever yeah but
in my hand I'm like even if I have to
take my iPhone out I'll make a movie do
you think that's become because people's
tastes change it's not so much that we
don't want to anymore it's just the
style and the and the taste and the tone
of movies changes I don't know I yeah
they do but I think I think a great
filmmaker you know unless they really
lost everything good about themselves if
they lost their soul but if they're
still a good human being they have
something to say it's not like you know
I must have done doing it I can't
imagine a guy like George Roy hill
couldn't make it he probably didn't want
to deal with all the politics anymore
I'm guessing I'm projecting I have no
idea so that's you know it's just sad
though that and I do think it's not fair
like what I wish Coppola Lee how cool
would be if Coppola came out with
another film we also now he has his
winery yeah you can have a winery and
make movies that's true I don't think
he's squeezing the grapes but even with
a one-hit wonder you always think is it
because they couldn't get another film
even remember the band Yeahs great
Alison Moyet yeah amazing choice and
they're not one-hit wonders but for a
long time they went away yeah no you
didn't hear about them so is it because
someone gives up on the business or the
business doesn't want them yeah I know
sometimes people are too difficult like
there's a film that I love called human
traffic and there was a British director
and it was about like the whole like
kind of ecstasy club scene and it was
like I saw it anyway that side it was a
very small audience side that I know
it's just like a really heartfelt
coming-of-age but very hip
because it dealt with like ecstasy and
kids doing drugs but like in the heart
of the movie was really really good and
I couldn't wait to see what that
director would do next and nothing I
keep everyone's all checking them and I
don't think he's done anything and I
don't know you know making a movie you
have to be a lot of things you have to
be a filmmaker you have to be a
therapist and I think you have to be a
politician and that's a hard part for a
lot of people and either the politics of
my least favorite part of it because you
get really distracted and frustrated and
but you know I just really want to make
film someone to do what I have to do
when it comes to you know and I try to
do from a positive place you know I'm
not arrogant seems to work - for
directors that's just I don't function
in that place so I think it's easier
though for some of those guys it seems
like you just like to laugh that's great
you